Hello Psych2Go-ers!
We just want to
take the time to thank you
for all your kind of support.
We are a team of
dedicated, passionate,
and hard-working individuals,
who come together every day
with one goal in mind:
We want to make psychology
come alive for you.
We are self-funded
and recently launched our Patreon!
If you enjoy the work we do
and find it meaningful,
please stick around
until the end of the video
for information on
how to get more involved with us,
and all the cool rewards
you can get from us.
Asking someone out
can be downright scary.
Your heart may be racing right now
just thinking about your crush.
You keep telling yourself
that today will be
the day you do it,
whether it's when you both
have physics class together,
through a text message
during your lunch break,
or a phone call
right before you head to bed.
One common misconception
about our dating culture,
is that the awkwardness
and sweaty palms
only happen in our teenage years.
But many adults can find it
just as nerve-wracking,
and struggle with it.
We understand how intimidating it is
to put yourself out there,
and want to help you practice
being open and vulnerable.
Here are 5 ways
to ask someone out.
1. Find a common ground.
Before asking someone out,
It's important to find out
whether you two have
something in common.
Instead of making generic small talk,
you can delve into topics
that help you get to
know each other better.
For instance,
You can talk about
recent movies or books
that made an impact on your life,
If you know that they have
also seen or read them.
You can also ask them
about what their passions,
interests, hobbies and dreams are.
Once you find something
that the two of you share,
you can converse with them
on a deeper level,
rather than having
dead-end conversations
that prevent the both of you
from growing closer.
2. Pick a safe activity.
Pick an activity
that allows the both of you to bond
and have a good time.
Going out for coffee or drinks,
a walk in the park,
or a museum are safe options
that aren't too overwhelming.
Make sure that
the location you pick,
isn't too crowded or noisy
that prevents you from
hearing each other speak.
This is especially important for introverts.
Is your crush an introvert?
Check out our video,
"5 dating tips for introverts"
for more helpful information.
It's commonly advised not to
go to the movie theater
as a first date,
because it doesn't give you
a chance to interact as much.
But if the two of you decide
to have ice cream
and talk about the film later,
It can act as an icebreaker,
and give you something to talk about.
3. It's cliche and overused,
but, be yourself.
You hear this line all the time,
but there's a reason why it's true.
When you're in a relationship with someone,
It's not about constantly
telling each other how great you are,
that leaves you no room
to be yourself on your bad days.
The same applies
to asking someone out.
Avoid sounding like a salesperson.
Instead, be authentic, and honest.
Let the other person know
that you think they're interesting,
and that you're willing
to learn more about them.
Remember not to be pushy or forceful.
After all, you can't make someone
return the same feelings.
Respecting each other's space
and boundaries is important.
4. Figure out where
you want to ask them.
In this day and age,
we can text, email,
or call our crushes
when we want to ask them out.
Asking someone out in person
is also an option,
but it may be used
less often nowadays,
because of how intimidating it can be.
Depending on how long
you have known the person,
and whether or not the two of you
have exchanged phone numbers,
added each other on social media,
or have mutual friends,
figure out which method
works best for you.
Keep in mind that each platform
has its own pros and cons.
For instance,
Asking someone out in person
doesn't give you a chance
to retype a message,
but it does allow you
to see their reaction,
and their answer will be immediate,
rather than waiting
to hear back from a text.
5. Be brave, take the leap!
Don't wait too long
to make your move,
seize the day!
It's scary putting
your heart on the line,
but you never know
what may happen if you don't try.
Constantly letting your fears and thoughts
dwell up inside of you,
will only allow
your walls to grow higher.
It's better to take a chance,
than look back
with regrets and what-ifs.
There will be times
they'll be rejected,
but, remember that
this only brings you closer
to the person
you're meant to be with.
We wish you the best of luck!
Do you have trouble
working up the courage
to ask someone out?
Please share your thoughts
with us below!
Also, don't forget to subscribe
for more content from Psych2go,
and check out our Patreon!
We started it,
because we want to grow
into a bigger platform
that reaches more people
who are in need of help.
With your contribution,
you can receive our psy pendant,
t-shirt, issues of our magazine
and many more membership benefits!
Your funding will help us
produce quality scripts writing,
voice overs, and animation,
that makes our content
both entertaining, and educational.
We want to make sure
our community members
get the best,
and only the best.
Thanks for watching!